The look on your face just says like, okay, so for the audience, I'm a few minutes late and I just joined the call and I was expecting, I was expecting Connor to be doing something else, but no, he's just sitting there staring at the camera as if he's just been sitting there still doing nothing else for the past, for the past half an hour. I'm sorry, buddy. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 33 recorded on June 26, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we have a casual chat about Bryce's impending move to New York City
你脸上的表情就在说，好吧，对于听众朋友们，我迟到了几分钟，我刚加入通话，我本以为，我本以为康纳会在做别的什么，但并没有，他只是坐在那里盯着摄像头，好像他已经在那里一动不动地坐了过去，过去半个小时什么都没做一样。对不起，伙计。欢迎收看 ADSP 播客第 33 期节目，录制于 2021 年 6 月 26 日。我是康纳，今天我的联合主持人布莱斯也在，我们正在随性地聊聊布莱斯即将搬到纽约市的事
and also the upcoming 2022 ISO C++ committee meetings. So, yeah, I'm sorry I was late. I do this thing now where I eat breakfast after my morning bikes bike ride so uh and um uh I I did a very intensive bike ride yesterday um broke a new personal record whoo um but then this morning I got out to bike ride and I was just like oh my god I'm I'm old nothing works this is gonna take forever what was the personal record you broke? Distance? Speed? Yeah, just like average speed. Nice.
还有即将到来的 2022 年 ISO C++ 委员会会议。所以，是的，很抱歉我迟到了。我现在养成了一个习惯，就是晨骑之后吃早餐，所以呃，然后，呃，我，我昨天进行了一场非常高强度的骑行，打破了个人新纪录，呜——但是今天早上我出去骑车时，我心想，哦天哪，我老了，什么都不中用了，这要花好长时间啊。你打破了什么纪录？距离？速度？对，就是平均速度。太棒了。
So I did, yesterday I did 20 kilometers at an average speed of 30 kilometers an hour. And I usually do around that distance at an average speed of 28 kilometers an hour. So, you know, you're, you're when you're like, like training, you're supposed to either increase your velocity or your distance. So I had been working on increasing distance for a while and now I've been working on upping my velocity. But anyways, so I got back a little bit, a little bit later than expected. And then I had to shower and I had to have my breakfast cheese. And I was like, I could come 10 minutes earlier to the podcast and just eat my breakfast cheese during the podcast, but it's a podcast. So me eating cheese and crackers probably isn't going to come over that well just and to be clear a few minutes
所以我昨天骑了 20 公里，平均速度是每小时 30 公里。我通常是以每小时 28 公里的平均速度骑差不多的距离。所以，你知道，你在训练时，理应提高你的速度或你的距离。所以我一直在努力增加距离，现在我开始练习提升速度了。不管怎样，我回来得稍微晚了一点，比预期晚了一点。然后我得洗澡，还得吃我的早餐奶酪。我当时想，我可以早 10 分钟来录播客，然后在播客里吃我的早餐奶酪，但这毕竟是个播客。所以我在上面吃奶酪和饼干可能效果不太好，而且澄清一下，几分钟
by a few minutes what bryce means is 33 minutes it was 30 minutes it was it was 33 it was 33 i'm sorry it's all it's all right i mean i was 50 minutes late for the last one and we had guests that time so um when are you moving i was half expecting you to be in new york uh because you took no i move august 25th and uh um i'm flying out next week actually like like eight days i fly out to new york to go find a place yeah is it eight no maybe it's like two weeks no i guess it's basically like next week i fly out on the 7th there's a lot of big c++ names moving between uh companies you know about one of we can't say it yet but you know about one of them that's happening it's coming in video somebody coming to nvidia yeah i'm very excited about yes as am i
几分钟，布莱斯所指的其实是 33 分钟。是 30 分钟，是 33，是 33 分钟，我很抱歉。没关系，没关系，我是说我上一次迟到了 15 分钟，那次我们还有嘉宾呢，所以，呃，你什么时候搬家？我本来还以为你已经在纽约了，因为你没有——不，我 8 月 25 日搬家，呃，下周我就要飞过去了，实际上就像八天后我就要飞去纽约找房子了。是八天吗？不，也许是两周？不，我想基本上就是下周吧，我 7 号飞。你知道有些 C++ 界的大人物在各大公司之间跳槽吗？你知道其中一个，我们现在还不能说，但你知道其中一个正在发生的跳槽，有人要来英伟达了。有人要来英伟达，是的，我非常期待。我也是。
drama do i leave this do i leave this in the podcast uh i because i oh yeah i definitely do anyways how things been man this so yeah our for our listeners, it's been, what, May 12th was, I think, the last time we actually had an episode where it was just me. Was it? Yeah, it's been like a month and a half because. Oh, but we've talked since then, yeah. It's just that we haven't had an episode of just me and you since then. Have we talked since then? I'm not even sure yeah because we recorded the we recorded the one with patricia and the the patricia and uh
太抓马了，我该把这个剪掉吗，我该留在播客里吗？因为我，哦对，我肯定留着。不管怎样，最近怎么样，老兄？所以，是的，对我们的听众来说，上次我们录制只有我们俩的节目是什么时候来着，好像是 5 月 12 日吧？是吗？对，已经过去一个半月了，因为……哦，不过我们之后也聊过，是的。只是自那以后，我们一直没有录制过只有我和你的节目。我们之后聊过吗？我甚至都不确定，是的，因为我们录制了帕特里夏的那期，帕特里夏和，呃……
and yeah but chandler i don't i don't count the i don't count those though because it's different whenever we because we we did sean yeah but i'm just saying it's like it's like it's not like we have not had a conversation right right right we we do technically have a weekly one hour one-on-one on our on my calendar but um between my move and uh just stuff at work it's just been so hectic the past few few weeks um yeah yeah no in and I mean, I'm doing good. It's just like, I'm just starting to get into moving mode. And in the past, when I've moved, I think I've, I've always like left a lot of the things to the last minute, or I've been super time constrained. And so as a result of that, I'm like over planning this move. Like, like, as an example, I, my mom's gonna be flying out for for two weeks or so in August, help me pack. And for listeners who don't know, so I was an only child raised by a single parent until my mom remarried when I think I was 14. So we have a we have sort of like a Gilmore Girls-esque connection. I'm just going to leave that reference there for anybody who can appreciate it.
还有钱德勒，但我，我不把那个算在内，我不把那些算作我们俩的节目，因为只要我们跟肖恩一起录的时候就不一样。我是说，这并不是说我们没有交流过，对对对。我们日程表上其实每周都有一个小时的独处时间，但在我搬家和工作事务的双重夹击下，过去的几周实在是太忙碌了。是的，是的，不，我，我过得挺好的。就是，我刚开始进入搬家模式。在过去，当我搬家的时候，我想我总是把很多事情拖到最后一分钟，或者时间非常紧迫。因此，这次我对搬家进行了过度规划。比如，作为例子，我妈妈会在 8 月份飞过来待两周左右，帮我打包。对于不知道情况的听众，我是由单亲妈妈抚养长大的独生子，直到我大约 14 岁时我妈妈再婚。所以我们有一种类似《吉尔モ尔女孩》（Gilmore Girls）式的关系。我把这个梗放在这里，给能欣赏的人看。
But so like I told her, hey, can you come out and help me pack? Because I know it's going to be like emotional and stressful for me. And so she's coming out for two weeks in August. And I'm starting to realize, I think that there might not be anything for her to do by then. Because I've overplanned this move so much. Like I'm going to be starting to pack next week and i'm like like my strategy is i'm going to do like a box a day uh and you know then i'm going to be in new york for two weeks so i won't do any packing
但我跟她说，嘿，你能过来帮我打包吗？因为我知道这对我来说会充满情绪化而且压力很大。所以她八月份会来两周。而我开始意识到，到那时可能根本没什么需要她干的了。因为我对这次搬家的规划实在过度了。比如我下周就要开始打包了，我的策略是，我打算一天收拾一个箱子，然后，你知道的，我会在纽约待两周，所以我不会打包
then but i think there's a pretty good chance that she's going to show up here and then i'm going to mostly be done because my my strategy has been i'm just going to do it a little part like little pieces at a time right instead of like doing all of it in like, you know, two weeks where I just like take off work, I'm just like doing it in little chunks of the time. Like I've already gone and gotten rid of most of the stuff that I'm not taking. But it's just, you know, a move just, a move like this just consumes a lot of time. And then there's like a whole list of like California stuff that I feel like I got to do before I leave California. Like what? What are we doing?
在那期间，但我猜她很有可能来到这里时，我已经基本上都收拾完了，因为我的策略是，每次只做一点点，把任务拆成小块，而不是像那样全部集中在两周内完成，也就是请假把所有活干完。我是一点一点地做的。比如我已经把大部分不打算带走的东西都处理掉了。但你知道的，搬家，像这样的一场搬家总是会消耗大量时间。而且还有一整串我觉得在离开加州前必须处理完的加州本地事务。比如什么？我们在做什么？
Well, Christabella and I went to Lawson National Park last weekend. It was actually like funny timing so my my dad is uh is really outdoorsy and he got me a national parks pass last year for uh for like uh hanukkah um i think maybe it was number no i think it was hanukkah um and so i booked a bunch of uh trips to national parks over the summer um twice two to yosemite two trips to yosemite and then one to lawson and at the time i didn't know i was moving to new york and I didn't know that I was going to be selling my car which is my first car and like my my love and joy um uh and uh so I'm really glad that that like it was just really fateful that he'd gotten me that pass and then I'd booked those trips in January because like
嗯，上周末我和克里斯塔贝拉去了拉森火山国家公园。其实时间挺逗的——我爸爸非常喜欢户外活动，去年汉努卡节的时候他给我买了一张国家公园通票，我想也许是，不，我想那是汉努卡节。于是我预订了夏天去国家公园的一系列旅行，去两次优胜美地，然后去一次拉森。当时我并不知道我要搬去纽约，也不知道我要卖掉我的车，那可是我的第一辆车，我的心头肉。所以我真的很庆幸，他给我买那张通票并在 1 月份订好那些行程纯粹是命中注定，因为……
it's impossible to book reservations for anything now um if I if I'd only like done it now I wouldn't have been able to and like Yosemite you can't even get in to the park without like a reservation so so yes there's a bunch of that stuff and then um you know just been just been crazy with work but uh but yeah it's uh it's starting to get like real. Cause like I'm going out to New York in like a week to go look for places. So like my, uh, my time, like I sort of started feeling like six weeks ago, like, oh crap, like the move is here. Like my time in California is done and now it's all going to go very quickly. Like from this point forward until when I'm in New York, like it's just going to be a whirlwind and sort of like, like, yeah, like that I, I, I have not moved out of California yet,
现在根本不可能预订到任何地方的门票了，如果我现在才去弄，肯定订不到。比如优胜美地，没有预约的话甚至都进不去公园。所以，是的，有这么一堆事情要处理，然后，你知道的，工作上一直忙得不可开交，但是，但确实，事情开始变得真实了。因为我大约一周后就要去纽约找房子了。所以我，大约在六周前我就开始有这种感觉，天哪，搬家就在眼前了。我在加州的时光结束了，接下来一切都会过得飞快。从现在开始直到我安顿在纽约，这将是一场旋风般的旅程。就像是，是的，我还没搬离加州，
but I'm, I've reached the stage where stuff is going to happen quickly enough that and all this, you know, it'll all be changed that, that I've already effectively left that, you know, cause like when you're in the state where you're like packing up your apartment like you still don't live in that state you're sort of in a transitionary period um and so really like you know like May was my last real month uh in California uh I mean to some degree this this month but I was already
但我已经进入了这样一个阶段：事情的发展速度将足够快，这一切也都会随之改变，以至于我其实已经离开了，你知道的，因为当你处于打包公寓的状态时，你其实已经不再真正住在那座城市了，你正处于一个过渡期。所以实际上，你知道的，五月是我在加州的最后一个真正的月份——我是说某种程度上也包括这个月，但我其实已经
sort of in moving mode. Yeah. Are you excited? Yeah, I am excited. Yeah, I think it'll be really fun. I'm really looking forward to being closer to my grandparents. And, you know, I have a whole collection of friends that lives out here in Silicon Valley. A bunch of them are moving to other places too. But one of the nice things about the tech community that we're in is that it's sort of like a global community.
进入搬家模式了。是的。你感到兴奋吗？是的，我很兴奋。是的，我觉得这会很有趣。我非常期待能离我的祖父母更近一些。而且，你知道，我在硅谷这边有一群朋友。他们中的许多人也准备搬到其他地方去。但我们所处的科技圈的一个好处是，它有点像一个全球化社区。
So, you know, anywhere that I move, any major city that I move to, I just, I instantly know that there's going to be some number of people that I'm friendly with that happen to live in that city. Like, you know, it's, I don't know, I don't know how far the train is from Toronto to New York, but like, I think it's like, you know, a couple hours at most. What? Definitely. It's like four hours from Toronto to Montreal.
所以，你知道，无论我搬到哪里，无论我搬到哪座大城市，我立刻就会知道，总会有一些我熟悉的人碰巧也住在那个城市。就像，你知道的，我不知道，我不知道从多伦多到纽约的火车要开多久，但我想大概也就几个小时顶多了。什么？肯定的。从多伦多到蒙特利尔只要四小时。
Oh, okay. The train is like, I don't know, if we're, there's a Billy Bishop airport that's on Toronto Island, and it's like a 50-minute flight, and it's like $150, which, yes, very privileged. But if I'm going to New York, it's via plane. It's not a train. Okay, all right.
哦，好吧。坐火车，我不知道，如果我们说的话，多伦多岛上有一个比利·毕晓普机场，飞过去只要 50 分钟，票价大概 150 美元，好吧，这确实很特权。但如果我要去纽约，我是坐飞机去。不是坐火车。好吧，好吧。
But at least we'll be in the same time zone. And then there's a bunch of C++ people in New York that I'll be able to chill with. So, yeah, it's just this nice thing that like you know i there's a bunch of c++ people in new york um that i'll be able to chill with and so yeah it's just like it's just this nice thing that like you know the a pretty much anywhere i go in the world you know there's always going to be people that i know isn't like uh one of the plans first couple iso meetings going to be in new york yeah the um the next summer meeting um you know assuming that we have face-to-face meetings. So right now the plan is that the 2022 winter meeting, so the 2022 meeting that would be in February, is planned to be in Portland. And that's not actually a rescheduled meeting. That was like a meeting we planned pre pandemic. And it's actually a joint or two co-located meetings. The C committee is supposed to meet a week before that. So that meeting is the first one that we think might happen.
但至少我们会在同一个时区。纽约还有很多 C++ 圈的朋友，我可以和他们一起玩。所以，是的，这感觉很好，你知道，我在纽约有一帮 C++ 朋友，我可以和他们一起叙旧，所以，是的，这真的很棒，你知道，无论我去到世界上哪个地方，总会有我认识的人。对了，头几场 ISO 会议是不是有一场要在纽约开？对，明年的夏季会议，假设我们能有线下会议的话。所以目前的计划是，2022 年冬季会议，也就是 2022 年 2 月的那场会议，计划在波特兰举行。那其实不是延期的会议。那是我们大流行之前就计划好的会议。而且它实际上是一个联合会议或两个同地举办的会议。C 语言委员会应该在那之前一周开会。所以那场会议是我们认为可能会如期举行的第一场。
And then the New York meeting would be in, I think, June 2022 um so right now the plan is like we're assuming that those are going to happen but you know we really don't know yeah um to tell uh it's too early to tell but i i i think it's you know it's looking good right now the thing that i worry about now is not um not whether we can hold the meeting it's whether we can hold the meeting equitably yeah um you know if if you hold if you obviously it's going to be a hybrid event you know no matter how we do it it's going to be a hybrid event uh prior to the pandemic the um committee, the C++ committee meetings largely didn't allow for remote attendance. And that didn't mean that we forbid remote attendance. You weren't allowed to vote in plenary motions if you were attending remotely. But honestly, voting on plenary motions
然后纽约会议将会在，我想是 2022 年 6 月举行。所以目前的计划是，我们假设这些会议都会举行，但老实说，我们真的无法确定，是的，现在还很难说，但我认为，目前来看情况还不错。我现在担心的不是我们能不能开会，而是我们能不能以公平的方式开会。是的，如果你举办，显然这将是一场混合会议，无论我们怎么做，这都将是一场混合会议。在大流行之前，C++ 委员会会议基本上不允许远程参与。这并不意味着我们禁止远程参与。如果你是远程参加，你就不能在全员大会（Plenary）的动议中投票。但老实说，在全员大会动议上投票
is not really what participating in the committee meeting is. I always say to people, your voice is much louder than your vote. Your vote is almost not, it's not something to lose sleep over. And this is like, I tell this in particular to there are some folks who, for a variety of reasons, don't have voting rights in the committee. And, you know, I have to tell them that's not
并不是参加委员会会议的真正核心。我总是对人们说，你的声音比你的投票权重要得多。你的投票几乎不算什么，不值得为此失眠。特别是，我会这样告诉那些由于各种原因在委员会中没有投票权的人。而且，你知道，我必须告诉他们，这其实
really, you know, super, super relevant. Your votes in subgroups, what we call straw polls, those are a little bit more important. But again, even there, your voice is just far more important than your vote. So you're not allowed to formally vote in the plenary motions if you attended remotely pre-pandemic. And we didn't really have any infrastructure in place for allowing remote attendance. There were some people that had attended remotely for some discussions in some special circumstances. For example, Chris Kolhoff, who lives in Australia and for whom it is difficult to travel to a committee meeting,
并没有那么重要。你在小组里的投票，也就是我们所说的非正式投票（straw polls），会稍微重要一点。但即便如此，你的声音也远比你的投票重要得多。所以在大流行前，如果你远程参加，你是不能在全员动议中正式投票的。而且我们也没有建立任何允许远程参与的基础设施。在某些特殊情况下，确实有一些人远程参加过一些讨论。例如，克里斯·科尔霍夫（Chris Kolhoff），他住在澳大利亚，对（他来说，前往委员会参加会议非常困难），
not just because of the time zones, but also because of work. He's not always been able to, you know, take the time off of work to go and travel to a committee meeting for a week. And I could be wrong, but I believe that he's an independent contractor. So he would not only be taking a week off work, but he'd be paying for it himself. And so you can understand why he might not be excited about the idea of paying a bunch of money to fly for a week to some location that's very far away from home when there's only, you know, one day of things maybe that would be of interest to him. So I recall him calling into, you know, some meeting in 2017 or 2018. And I recall that happening like a couple times,
不仅因为时区问题，还因为工作原因。他并不总能抽出时间请假去参加为期一周的委员会会议。我可能记错了，但我相信他是一名独立承包商。所以他不仅要请一周的假，还要自掏腰包。所以你可以理解为什么他可能不会对花一大笔钱飞到离家很远的地方待上一周感到兴奋，而那里可能只有一天的事情是对他感兴趣的。我记得他在 2017 年或 2018 年曾拨号接入过某个会议，
but it was always like one or two people, like a special case. Definitely the pandemic has changed that. And I think definitely post pandemic, the committee meetings will be hybrid. And I don't think that that's just going to be a temporary thing. I suspect that that will be a long-term thing that you'll be able to attend remotely. I don't know about voting, but again, well, okay, do we have the teleconferencing equipment to make this happen? Do we have the webcams to make this happen? Do we have a way for them to feel like they're in the room, to raise their hand, et cetera? I recall in one particular case where somebody was listening remotely, but they didn't have a way to speak to the room. And the way that they voiced their input was they would send a message on IRC to Jonathan Wakely, and then Jonathan it didn't express what they were trying to get across very well. So I imagine that we'll do better on the infrastructure there, you know, that we'll probably make sure that we have a teleconferencing solution at whatever venues we're at. But I still think that there's a problem
我记得这种情况发生过好几次，但总是只有一两个人，属于特例。大流行绝对改变了这一点。我认为大流行之后，委员会会议绝对会是线上的。我不认为这只是一次性的临时举措。我怀疑这将是一项长期机制，你将能够远程参加。我不确定投票权的问题，不过话说回来，好吧，我们有进行电话会议的设备来实现这一点吗？我们有网络摄像头来实现这一点吗？我们有办法让他们感觉自己身处房间内、能够举手发言等等吗？我记得有一次，有人在远程旁听，但他们没有办法向会场发言。他们表达意见的方式是给乔纳森·沃克利（Jonathan Wakely）发 IRC 消息，然后由乔纳森代为传达，这并不能很好地表达他们的想法。所以我相信我们在基础设施方面会做得更好，你知道的，我们可能会确保在任何开会地点都提供电话会议解决方案。但我仍然认为这里存在一个问题，
of equal access, especially, you know, if it's possible for us to meet in the U.S., but it's not really possible for a bunch of people from outside the U.S. to attend. You know, the C++ committee is supposed to be this international effort. And so if the Portland meeting and the New York meeting are going to be held in the, so the US obviously already has an outsized influence on C++ because, you know, the majority of committee members are located in the U S. Um, it's probably true that the majority of committee members are American citizens. Um, uh, the U S tends to have an over, um, uh, uh, to be very overrepresented in tech standards. Would you say it's a majority? It's definitely a plurality. Um, is it, do you think it's more than 50% yes i i'm almost certain that it is i guess the meetings that i've been to were all in europe so maybe that yeah that influences that i saw more europeans because they were held in europe but probably
特别是关于机会均等的问题，尤其是如果我们能在美国开会，但大量非美国本土的人无法真正出席。你知道的，C++ 委员会本应是一项国际性的工作。如果波特兰会议和纽约会议都在美国举行——因为美国对 C++ 的影响本就过大，因为大多数委员会成员都位于美国。可能确实大多数委员会成员都是美国公民，美国在技术标准方面往往过度代表。你会说这是大多数吗？这绝对占多数。你觉得超过 50% 了吗？是的，我几乎可以肯定。我猜我参加过的会议都在欧洲，所以也许这影响了我的观感，我看到更多欧洲人是因为会议在欧洲举行，但美国的会议可能
the ones in the u.s or less so the way to do them the way to do the math on this is quite simple. I don't even have to log into the Insights website and check how many members are on the roster to to a particular working group. And the U.S. is so far over that limit that a few years ago, the U.S. national body for the C++ committee got together and agreed that they would only register one person from each U.S. company as an official representative because that was the only way to fit within that 100-person limit. So the U.S. delegation is definitely well over 100 members. And even at our largest committee meeting, we only had, you know, 250 or so attendees. I'm fairly certain that the U.S. is definitely a majority of committee, or that the majority of committee members are U.S. citizens. But anyways, so let's say that we have this Portland meeting and that, like, let's just assume that pretty much only the U.S. based folks are able to attend that meeting. And of course, there are some people who are member who are not U.S. citizens or who have dual citizenship, but live in the U.S.
就没那么多了。计算这个的数学方法很简单。我甚至不需要登录 Insights 网站去检查特定工作组的名单上有多少成员。美国的注册人数远远超过了那个限制。几年前，C++ 委员会的美国国家代表机构（US national body）聚集在一起并达成一致：他们每个美国公司只注册一个人作为官方代表，因为那是符合 100 人限制的唯一方法。所以美国代表团的成员绝对远超 100 人。即使在我们规模最大的委员会会议上，我们也只有大约 250 名左右的与会者。我相当确信美国代表绝对占了委员会的大多数，或者说大多数委员会成员都是美国公民。不管怎样，假设我们召开了这次波特兰会议，并且，假设基本上只有美国本地的人能够出席该会议。当然，也有一些成员本身不是美国公民，或者拥有双重国籍但居住在美国，
And so they represent other countries or other regions on the committee. And so maybe they could attend, but still, basically, you'd have a situation where all the U.S. folks would be at the face-to-face meeting and all the non-U.S. folks would have to attend that meeting remotely via telecom. And because the meeting's a hybrid meeting, you don't really have the luxury of picking time zones that are, you know, friendly to the rest of the world. ISO's general guidance for meetings now is to pick a rotating time slots. So they identified three time slots that are good for different regions of the world. And their advice is basically for each meeting or, you know, each day of your meeting, pick one of these time slots. And, you know, for any one person, some of these slots are going to suck. But the idea is that by rotating through the slots, you know, some people, there will be some slots that are good for some people um but i can just imagine that
因此他们代表委员会的其他国家或地区。所以也许他们可以出席，但基本上，你仍然会面临这样一种情况：所有美国人都将参加现场会议，而所有非美国人都必须通过电信远程参加。由于会议是混合会议，你就没有奢侈的选择对世界其他地方友好的时区。ISO 目前对会议的一般指导方针是选择轮换的时间段。他们确定了三个适合世界不同地区的时区。他们的建议基本上是为每次会议（或会议的每一天）选择其中一个时区。对于任何一个人来说，其中某些时段会很糟糕。但这个想法是，通过轮换这些时段，对某些人来说总会有合适的时段。但我可以想象，
that it'll be problematic to ensure that um uh that we really that we can hold these hybrid meetings in a way that um is fair for all the participants regardless of what country they're living in yeah i guess time will tell to see how it unfolds. One, if it even happens and two, how it's executed. And I am proud of the ways in which the C++ committee has been able to evolve during the pandemic. I think many people who know me know that I believe, I'm very much a logistics and process guy and so I very much believe that the C++ committee needs to modernize
确保我们能够以对所有参与者（无论他们居住在哪个国家）都公平的方式举办这些混合会议，将会是一个棘手的问题。是的，时间会证明一切，看它将如何展开。第一，它是否会发生；第二，它是如何执行的。我为 C++ 委员会在大流行期间能够不断演进的方式感到自豪。许多了解我的人都知道我相信，我非常注重物流和流程，所以我坚信 C++ 委员会需要现代化
how we evolve C++ a lot of our infrastructure is somewhat outdated our model is somewhat outdated it should be more open it should look more like how newer standards, some of the web standards are developed. And we've taken great strides during the pandemic to modernizing our process. We've done all of our evolution for the past year on telecons and on mailing list reviews. And we do a lot more of our evolution
我们演进 C++ 的方式。我们的很多基础设施有些过时了，我们的模式有些过时了，它应该更加开放，看起来应该更像是那些更新的标准、一些网络标准的开发方式。在大流行期间，我们在实现流程现代化方面迈出了巨大步伐。过去一年里，我们的所有演进工作都是通过电话会议和邮件列表评审完成的。我们将更多的演进工作放到了
on github um but i still don't think we've we've really come far enough i still don't think that our evolution process really um mirrors what the best practice is you You know, we, there's a big gap between how C++ is evolved and how a language like Rust is evolved, where, you know, pretty much all the Rust evolution happens, you know, online on their forums. And the thing that saddens me a little bit is that we're still a long way away from where I think we need to be. And even this, even these sort of strides that we've made
GitHub 上，但我仍然认为我们走得还不够远。我仍然认为我们的演进流程并没有真正反映出最佳实践。你知道的，C++ 的演进方式和 Rust 这种语言的演进方式之间存在着巨大的鸿沟，Rust 的演进几乎全是在线上的论坛上进行的。让我感到有点伤感的是，我们距离我认为需要达到的目标还有很长的路要走。甚至连这些，我们在过去一年中取得的这些进展，
in the last year, they've made it clear that it's going to take a longer time to change the culture than we might like, because the participation level just has not been the same in the past year. And we just, we have not had the same bandwidth, even with doing these telecons, and even with doing reviews on things like, you know, over email, we're just not getting the same bandwidth and engagement. So as much as I hate to admit it, we really need these face to face committee meetings next year to be able to really finish C++23. And the reason that we need them is because as much as I hate to admit it, we're just not getting enough work done through the purely virtual process. And I mean, I think we're getting better at the virtual process. And I think a lot of the innovations that we've made will continue
它们也清楚地表明，改变文化所需的时间可能会比我们期望的要长，因为过去一年的参与度并没有达到预期。我们根本没有足够的带宽，即使开了这些电话会议，甚至通过电子邮件进行评审，我们的带宽和参与度也大不如前。因此，尽管我很不愿意承认，我们明年的线下委员会会议真的是必需的，只有这样才能真正完成 C++23。我们需要它们的原因是，尽管我极不情愿承认，但通过纯粹的虚拟流程，我们确实无法完成足够的工作。我的意思是，我认为我们在虚拟流程方面正在变得更好，而且我认为我们做出的大许多创新将会继续下去，
but there's there's still a long way to go and i think the problem is not actually in the technical details or the process itself i think it's in the culture and it's really hard to change culture yeah that's for sure so what about you how have you been i'm good i booked my haircut while waiting for you to show up uh on the first day it's possible to get a haircut because we both do need haircuts i'm not cutting my hair which is now pretty long and curly until at least until i moved to new york and i might keep it for a while there yeah you're yours looks good. I like the look on you. Yeah. Yeah.
但前方依然任重道远。我认为问题其实不在于技术细节或流程本身，而在于文化，而改变文化真的很难。是的，这是肯定的。那么你呢？你最近怎么样？我挺好的，在你出现之前我预约了理发，就在理发店重新开业的第一天，因为我们俩确实都需要理发。我不会剪头发，我现在头发又长又卷，至少在搬到纽约之前我不会剪，而且到了那边我也可能会留上一段时间。是的，你的发型很好看。我很喜欢你现在的样子。是的。
And I mean, I now pretty much always have to have it with a headband up and a hair scrunchie in. I have a newfound appreciation for people with long hair. But my mom's hairstylist has curly hair, too. And so she prescribed a whole regime for me and so my bathroom i have like 300 of like five different hair products that i put in my hair to is it is it regime or is it regimen i feel like regime is like a regimen i think yeah yeah regime is like a political uh i think you're right yeah you know i'm bad at words but but you know i have i have really thick curly hair and for many years for many years and i i blame
我是说，现在我基本上总是得用发箍把头发束起来，再扎个发圈。我对留长发的人有了全新的认识。但我妈妈的发型师头发也是卷的，所以她给我开了一整套护肤保养方案——是“方案（regime）”还是“疗程（regimen）”？我觉得 regime 像是……是个政权，我觉得你是对的。是的，你知道我不擅长词汇。但你知道的，我有非常浓密的卷发，很多年里，很多年我都把这归咎于
i blame my mother for this for many years um uh i was taught and trained to fight the curliness of my hair you know to try to keep it short, try to make it, you know, nice and straight, get it in a comb over. And it's only been as an adult that I've realized that my hair looks just fine if it's curly and like properly maintained.
我把这怪罪于我母亲。很多年里，呃，我被教导和训练去对抗我头发的卷曲，你知道的，试着把它剪短，试着让它保持漂亮直顺，梳成大背头。直到成年后我才意识到，如果我的头发是卷的并且得到了正确的护理，其实看起来挺不错的。
And that is just like a better life to live than trying to make this incredibly curly hair do anything else. Yep. I like it. You have to stick with it. Mine, it just, it's getting in the way. I've been running a lot. Oh, yeah, I'm about to break my monthly running record.
比起试着让这头极其卷曲的头发做别的事情，这样生活要美好得多。确实如此。我喜欢。你得坚持下去。我的头发，它只是，它开始碍事了。我一直在大量跑步。哦，是的，我快要打破我每月的跑步记录了。
Oh, congrats. What's your monthly running record? I think last summer I ran 454 kilometers one month. Right now I'm at 4 thirty six and there's like what five days left or not four days left oh yeah also too should we say something about pride month I realized when we caught we we recorded the Patricia Chandler three hour mega episode which turned into you know four episodes and then how are you what how are you how are you running that much because i'm not even biking that much i don't know i guess i uh people people are always like oh you must have no free time for
哦，恭喜。你的月跑步记录是多少？我想去年夏天我有一个月跑了 454 公里。现在我跑了 436 公里，大概还有，什么，还有五天？不对，还有四天。哦对了，顺便问一下，我们是不是该聊聊骄傲月（Pride Month）的事？我意识到当我们录制帕特里夏和钱德勒那个三小时超级大巨集时——它后来变成了四集——你是怎么，你怎么能跑那么多公里？我甚至都没有骑那么多车！我不知道，我猜我，人们总是说：“哦，你肯定没有空闲时间做
anything and 400 kilometers a month over 30 days is 13k a day which i can run in 60 minutes yeah okay i guess like like like this this week i did 120 kilometers last week because i was hiking in lawson i did 84 the week before i did 135 before that i did 142 so i'm like averaging like 120 a week okay yeah so yeah if you if you basically run every day which i usually take like one or two days off a month and that's the is like, that doesn't mean I'm running crazy hard every day. Like I don't really do tempo days. I, I run either like a decent pace or I take it easy.
任何事了。”一个月跑 400 公里，在 30 天里平均每天 13 公里，我可以在 60 分钟内跑完。是的，好吧，就像这周我跑了 120 公里，上周因为我在拉森徒步，我跑了 84 公里，再上周我跑了 135 公里，再之前是 142 公里，所以我差不多每周平均跑 120 公里。好吧，是的。所以，如果你基本上每天都跑步——我通常一个月只休息一两天——这意味着我并不是每天都跑得疯狂卖力。我其实不怎么跑节奏跑。我要么以不错的配速跑，要么就轻松跑。
So like my, my easy days are like my break days. Um, yeah. And, uh, I, I,
所以我的轻松日就像是休息日。是的。而且，我，我
I used, I used to do, I used to do a longer ride on Saturdays and then a shorter ride on most of the weekdays. So I don't bike every day. I have two days a week that I do yoga with my mom. I do exercise every day. I guess that's the difference between us. You do it every day, basically.
以前习惯在周六进行长途骑行，然后在大多数工作日进行短途骑行。所以我不是每天都骑车。我一周有两天和我妈妈一起做瑜伽。我每天都锻炼。我想这就是我们之间的区别。你基本上每天都锻炼。
I have two days a week I do something else. But now I just do the same route every day. And some days I do like an extra three kilometers. Like the route is like 25 kilometers if I do it exactly. But some days I'll do an extra like three to five. And I used to go to two different bike trails, but now I just go to one just because it's like, I don't know, it's like flatter and more consistent and like closer. And I used to bike to the bike trail, but it's just like more time efficient for me to drive there and then get in a longer, higher intensity workout. Yeah.
我一周有两天做别的事。但现在我每天都跑同一条路线。有些日子我会多跑三公里。如果准确按路线跑是 25 公里，但有些日子我会多跑三到五公里。我以前去过两条不同的自行车道，但现在我只去一条，因为，我不知道，它更平坦、更稳定、离得更近。我以前骑车去自行车道，但开车去那里对我来说更省时，能让我进行更长时间、更高强度的锻炼。是的。
Anyways, yeah. So just running lots. But are we supposed to happy pride month i just think yeah we should definitely say something about pride what should we say uh happy pride month um two white guys who consider themselves allies figure out what to say at the end of pride and this won't even come out in pride month this will come out post pride month yeah let's see what should we say what do we say to all our uh lgbtq a plus listeners oh hang on you're breaking up for me no i didn't break up i just i just stopped talking yeah
不管怎样，是的。就是跑了很多步。不过我们是不是应该说声“骄傲月快乐”？我觉得，是的，我们绝对应该说点关于骄傲月的事。我们该说些什么呢？“两个自认是盟友的白人男子试图在骄傲月结束时想好该说些什么”，而且这期节目播出时甚至都已经过完骄傲月了，这会在骄傲月之后才发布。好吧，让我们看看该说些什么。我们对所有 LGBTQIA+ 听众说些什么呢？哦等等，我的信号断断续续的。不，我没断，我只是不说话了。是的，
that was the start of saying something oh man this this podcast is going to be just a mess to edit um yeah happy pride month happy pride month all right i'll cut this up real nice thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed happy belated pride month and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是说点什么的前兆。天哪，这期播客剪辑起来绝对会是一场灾难。是的，骄傲月快乐！骄傲月快乐！好吧，我会把这段剪得漂漂亮亮的。感谢收听，希望你们喜欢。祝大家补过骄傲月快乐，度过美好的一天！本集节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。